dans un instant sur ce plateau daniel
homogène ce qu'il est le responsable des
jeunes ump dans la 11e circonscription
des yvelines auparavant c'est vous qui
avez la parole que pensez vous de cette
crise de ce chaos à l'ump ce feuilleton
qui semble ne devoir jamais se terminer
catastrophique je trouve que c'est
déplorable
c'est dommage je pense ça se réduit
rapidement
ça n'est pas une bonne représentation
des hommes politiques alors moi qui suis
principal d'un collège et que je fais
tous les jours d éducation à la
citoyenneté bon comportement et où je
trouve ça scandaleux ben je trouve que
c'est laid c'est d'un ridicule et puis
que les gens en ont marre en fait
d'entendre toutes petites guéguerres et
qu'on aboutisse à rien et je trouve que
ce n'est pas l'image de la france de
voir des politiques
se traiter comme ça et puis agir de la
façon dont ils agissent quoi il
critiquait la gauche parce que parce que
six tirs et entre eux mais là c'est vrai
car
ils font la même chose en fait mais
bon soir à daniel brosinski bon ça vous
êtes le responsable jeunes ump dans la
11e circonscription des yvelines qui
couvre notamment elancourt trappe la
verrière ou encore le mesnil saint denis
avant toute chose déjà votre réaction
vient d'entendre un micro trottoir et
les gens sont plutôt déçus forcément ce
n'est pas une surprise que je vous
annonce par ce qui se passe à l'ump bien
sûr bien sûr qu'ils sont déçus c'est une
situation extrêmement difficile pour eux
je pense qu'il faut penser aux militants
qui est qui ont déjà vécu plusieurs
contenus défaite électorale dans ces
derniers temps et je pense qu'ils
avaient un espoir d'une relance d'une
dynamique en tant qu'opposition par
cette élection du président de l'ump est
forcément à cette situation est la pire
qu'on aurait pu imaginer et vous êtes
déçu aussi bien sûr que notre jeune
militant bien sûr qu'on est déçus c'est
difficile à
ne pas vous surprendre en disant que ce
n'est pas facile à gérer parmi les
militants
on va voir où en sont les discussions
entre jean-françois copé et françois
fillon va voir où ça mènera j'espère que
ça donnera quelque chose vous avez
presque 24 ans vous êtes rentré à l'ump
à ces jeunes finalement vous aviez
qu'elle a achetée en 2007 j'étais encore
au lycée pour cet engagement pour l'ump
car parce que c'était un moment où je
commence à me rendre compte de peine des
problématiques nationales et et je pense
que beaucoup de jeunes de ma génération
son arrivée en politique ont pris leur
carte à l'ump justement en 2007 on est
beaucoup parce que nicolas sarkozy avait
il faut le dire une
porte et un espoir exceptionnel et il
nous a vraiment exceptionnellement
motivés et aucun moment vous aviez pu
imaginer une telle situation regardons
maintenant maintenant mon pire cauchemar
non vraiment c'est improbable qu'une
situation et on pensait qu'on aurait
vécu le pire avec le congrès de reims au
ps mais on a pu faire mieux on va juste
rappeler les dernières évolutions dans
donc de ce feuilleton à l'ump le groupe
fillonniste air ump rassemblement ump
vient de faire son entrée à l'assemblée
aujourd'hui avec un temps de parole il a
pu poser ses questions au gouvernement
il siège à part de l'ump de voir cette
image de l'ump divisé l'aca officialise
véritablement les choses on n'est plus
dans les discussions dans les tensions
il ya deux groupes ça veut pas dire que
françois fillon a quitté l'ump ce
groupe-là reste affilié à l'ump oui et
c'est un bullet man en tout cas oui bien
sûr ça sonne assez si je pars i gotta
côte c'est un groupe à part bien sûr
bien sûr mais alors il faut voir aussi
qu'il ya de réelles
divergences de points de vues de
conception de la politique en somme
c'est entre ces deux groupes là et en ce
sens là c'est logique qu'ils soient
divisés parce que
le logo les députés qui suit françois
fillon et ceux qui suivent jean françois
copé n'ont pas du tout la même approche
je crois de la démocratie d'un parti ça
va être difficile de rabibocher tout le
monde de rafistoler le parti ça va être
difficile mais je pense que c'est encore
faisable malgré ce que vous dites vous
dites ya deux visions différentes mais
on peut ce lundi à des visions
différentes c'est à dire il faut
vraiment que chacun reprenne la raison
est que chacun accepte qu'on organise à
nouveau absolument un nouveau vote avec
une commission indépendante avec un vote
transparent et qu'on ne recommence plus
les mêmes erreurs qu'on a faites pendant
cet excès c'est avec cela et moi je vous
avais que je comprends pas vraiment la
position de jean françois copé et de ses
partisans de vouloir à tout prix se
cramponner à ce siège de président ump
je ne vois pas comment on peut un peu
exercé correctement cette fonction en se
sachant illégitime il le sait très bien
il le sait que l'élection était
contestée il le sait qu'il a soit disant
été proclamé président de l'ump avec
trois fédérations non quand voilà c'est
pas possible et il faut faire ce vote
dans dé bonnes conditions et je le
précise puisque je n'ai pas dit au début
mais c'est évident à vous écouter
françois fillon durant la campagne elle
a soutenu françois fillon absolue maury
et vous le soutiendrez tout le temps
c'est à dire que s'il décide de créer un
mouvement à part écoutez on n'en est pas
là moi j'attends vraiment je sais on
sait que jean françois copé et françois
fillon se sont rencontrés hier et
aujourd'hui c'est pas la première fois
il ya beaucoup ça semble pas avancer
pour bien sûr un serviteur mais bon on
garde espoir on n'en est pas là je ne
pense pas que ça arrive mais en tout cas
oui françois fillon représente une
certaine vie politique une certaine
conception de la politique et du
rassemblement et oui on le suivra
jusqu'au bout et bien sûr vous gardez
votre carte à l'ump est ce qu'il ya des
militants des jeunes militants ump du
département ou de votre circonscription
la 11e qui ont rendu leur carte c'est un
mythe on les a vu ces images on les a
vus a vu des images de leur carte ce qui
les rendait c'est sûr c'est pas c'est
pas des départs en masse pas du tout et
moi je le dis à mes militants jeudi à
nos jeunes c'est pas parce qu' un parti
connaît des difficultés chaque parti
démocratique a connu des difficultés on
peut regarder ils ont tous connu c'est
pas parce qu'un parti connaît des
difficultés qu'il faut le quitter et il
faut bien comprendre que si on quitte
l'ump maintenant ses rangs de la gauche
plus forte c'est rendre le fn plus fort
et je ne pense pas vraiment que ça
profitables je ne pense pas que ce soit
ce que veulent les militants pour autant
il est difficile de mener son travail
dans l'opposition lorsqu'on est divisée
au sein de son parti vous nous l'avez
dit vous souhaitez de nouvelles
élections comme françois fillon a écouté
la position de deux élus ump du
département à ce sujet valérie pécresse
est la présidente de la fédération des
yvelines député de la 2e circonscription
et puis christine boutin elle est
conseillère générale du département elle
est aussi présidente du parti chrétien
démocrate
elle nous donne toutes deux leurs
sentiments sur cette crise donc je suis
profondément optimiste je crois en la
politique et je pense encore que l'ump
peut sortir par le haut de cette crise à
condition pour vote à condition pour
redonne la parole aux militants et qu'on
fasse de cet exercice qui pour l'instant
est un exercice
raté un exercice réussi démocratie
interne et vous qu'est ce que vous
auriez envie de dire aux militants peut
être désabusé des yvelines président de
la fédération je voulais leur dire que
derrière ce qui apparaît comme un
exercice raté il y a des idées il ya des
hommes politiques et des femmes
politiques qui croient vraiment en la
politique qu'ils veulent servir leur
pays qui veulent faire avancer l'intérêt
général qui veulent se battre aussi
contre aujourd'hui certaines erreurs de
la gauche il y a encore dans ce pays des
hommes et des femmes politiques dignes
de foi je suis comme tous les français
de droite août sympathisants de droite
un peu désolée de ce spectacle vendredi
nous avons eu deux cents adhérents
supplémentaires ce qui est pour nous
important
mais de toute façon s'ils voulaient le
la question n'est pas la course à tout
cela parce qu'on est tous ensemble et
moi ce que je souhaite c'est que
l'opposition reprennent de la voix si on
part dans une élection on va perdre du
temps en corse et dire qu'il ya un temps
de campagne déjà on a eu la précédente
campagne qui a duré trois mois ça a été
très long dans ce temps-là on avait
d'autres préoccupations que notre devoir
républicain d'opposition pour parler de
problèmes internes là si on repart il y
aura des tensions ou bien sûr entre les
deux camps et puis est-ce qu'il n'y aura
pas de contestation après moi j'en sais
rien pendant ce temps là est bien le
temps s'écoule et la démocratie n'est
pas vivante donc vous vous dites le
président c'est jean françois copé moi
je pense oui je pense que oui je
maintenant écouter le principal c'est
qu'il arrive qu'ils arrivent à un accord
entre entre tout le monde il faut que
chacun
garde sur l'honneur
deux interview réalisée lundi il ya tout
juste quelques jours et puisque nous
venons d'entendre christine boutin
sachez que le conseiller municipal de
montigny le bretonneux mathieu colombani
a été nommé délégué général du parti
chrétien démocrate de christine boutin
il a aussi par le passé été le
collaborateur parlementaire de jean
frédéric poisson le député de la 10e
circonscription
on a entendu justement christie
maintenant à 10 ans perd du temps si on
fait des nouvelles élections elle a dit
que les propositions de jean françois
copé sont raisonnables moi je demande si
c'est vraiment raisonnable de garder ce
statut quo je ne pense pas que ce soit
raisonnable de rester une opposition
divisée il faut faire un nouveau vote ce
qui permettra de nous réunir à nouveau
et avoir un président légitime
incontesté et juste pour y répondre à
rebondir sur ce que 10 à valérie
pécresse elle disait qu'elle croit en la
politique et que c'est des idées avant
tout et je pense que c'est très vrai je
pense que c'est pour ça que je crois que
l'ump ne va pas se diviser qu'on va
garder l'ump c'est parce que il faut
rappeler aux militants que ce qui nous
unit d'abord ce ne sont pas des hommes
ce sont avant tout des valeurs et ces
valeurs là on les retrouve malgré tout
au sein de tous les militants de l'ump
l'interview donc je vous le disais tout
à l'heure réalisé il ya quelques jours
lundi en début de semaine en ce moment
avec les militants les jeunes militants
ump votre travail c'est quoi sur le
terrain c'est justement de militer pour
avoir une nouvelle campagne interne au
sein du parti ou de militer
véritablement en tant que force
d'opposition il faut être clair
cette campagne interne à la fatiguer
tout le monde nous on a du pain sur la
planche on a beaucoup de travail donc on
continue les activités qu'on faisait
déjà avant alors que ce soit des
activités plus ludiques on va aux
émissions de télé on s'intéresse au
débat politique actuel mais ce qu'on
veut absolument c'est surtout se
remettre au travail et ce travail là
c'est préparer 2014 les municipales qui
sont absolument essentielles pour
commencer cette vague bleue qu'on attend
tous c'est difficile de lancer la vague
bleue vous n'avez pas le sentiment que
pour l'ump ainsi 2014 il peut se passer
encore beaucoup de choses en quelques
jours il peut se passer encore beaucoup
de choses à l'ump dont quatre nouveaux
partis non non non comme je vous dis moi
je crois à l'unité de l'ump mais en tout
cas on prépare les élections de 2014 on
intéresse les jeunes à leur vie
politique locale on leur fait rencontrer
leurs élus on va aux conseils municipaux
on prépare tout ça on est au travail et
pour l'instant on laisse le haut de la
pyramide se débrouiller avec les
problèmes et nous on continue le travail
pendant ce temps là juste rappelé vous
parlez du haut de la pyramide mais il
devrait y avoir des il aurait dû en tout
cas même déjà y avoir des élections pour
le président des jeunes militants ump
ça va de soi qu'il faut d'abord ça va
être bien sûr que c'est bien sûr que ça
va porter pour le moment je pense que
c'est pour le coût raisonnable
d'attendre que toutes ces histoires sont
d'abord résolu et qu'ensuite on
choisisse notre président des jeunes
merci à daniel brosinski merci à un
jeune militant ump responsable de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines d'être venu
sur ce plateau le 7-8 est terminé pour
ce soir c'est la fin de cette édition du
5 décembre je vous retrouve demain en
direct dès 18 heures avec de nouveaux
invités une large séquence consacrée au
téléthon qui se prépare bonne soirée